mais les concessions que j'ai vu faire
c'était d'accepter qu'il d'alcool au
mariage mais pour la fontaine donc
qu'ils étaient pour tout le monde
on a opté pour un jus de raisin
pétillant avec de la musique française
voilà avec johnny hallyday en font aussi
un ami moi c'est youssef j'ai 30 ans je
suis marié depuis août de l'es19 avec
marine et donc j'ai grandi au maroc je
suis musulman croyant pratiquant et je
vis en france depuis onze ans moi c'est
marilyn donc j'ai 27 ans moi je suis
donc catholique je vais à la messe
ça montrait une soirée salsa par hasard
ou tel que pour autre chose dont les
sorties au moment de la soirée salsa on
n'a plus les mêmes métro sur les mots
qu'elle a sur lequel tu m'as fait danser
la salsa et ils voient ce routeur du
trou j'étais vraiment fasciné par toi je
ne mangeais plus je dormais plus et
j'avais jamais ressenti quelque chose de
fort comme ça et je sentais que je
rentrais petit à petit dans ton dans son
univers et
et que j'avais envie d'y entrer pour
toujours toi tu est projeté par un de
ses amis
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit quand tu leur
as dit que tu sortais avec une française
catholique
il n'y a pas eu de vraie opposition mes
parents ils ont très bien accepté la
seule condition c'était que je sois là
heureux avec toi puissent les oncles et
tantes on peut avoir des petites blagues
des
des petites remarques ou c'est
l'entourage est ce qu'elle va se
convertir
est ce que tu es sûr est-ce qu'il ya pas
assez de jalu marocaine vous avez une
remarque marocain qui me disaient mais
tu viens d'être naturalisé normal quand
on se marier avec une catholique si
apple pas de fatigue il a tâté
paupiettes ingénieurs pourront
contempler dit ça comme toi j'ai quand
même eu la chance de ne pas avoir
d'opposition en tout cas d'opposition de
la part des personnes qui comptent
vraiment pour moi j'ai eu des questions
sur dame est ce que j'allais pouvoir
garder toute la liberté avec toi est ce
que j'avais pouvait regarder toute mon
indépendance puisque son père pauli ses
papilles avec moi pour avoir les papiers
j'ai toujours été sûr que je me marierai
à l'église et donc ça pour moi j'aurais
pas pu ne pas marier à l'église je suis
prête à beaucoup de choses mais ça
serait parité enfin si j'aurais fait
pour toi mais ça aurait été vraiment
extrêmement dur et je pense que ça
aurait mérité cent pour notre relation
que je fasse un tel sacrifice
moi j'avais de deux exigences c'était
que qu'il y ait aussi de la musique
orientale
parce que pour ma famille et mes amis
un mariage il faut beaucoup dansé sur
des musiques dans ok et le deuxième
point c'était la tradition de la mairie
donc pour ceux qui connaissent pas c'est
le fait de porter les mariés sur des
trônes et vie du coup on s'est mis en
tenue traditionnelle 230e les
traditionnels bien sûr majorque ont opté
pour une cérémonie selon chrétienne à
l'église avec un prêtre et un diacre et
un islamologue pas un animal mais un
musulman qui s'appelle hakim qui connaît
le coran par coeur pour notre famille
moi j'étais ouvert là deux possibilités
soit mon ouvrage août et on tombe bien
ben moi j'ai toujours voulu prendre le
nom de mon mari est gardé un espacement
là et avait pas peur que ça soit
peut-être un frein à ta carrière
vue professionnel non je pense que c'est
plutôt un un filtre parce que du coup
s'il ya des personnes qui ne souhaitent
pas travailler avec quelqu'un qui porte
mon mandat je serai très contente de ne
pas travailler avec eux bah du coup ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on s'est dit pour la
région ce serait que chacun de me2
éveille nos enfants à sa propre religion
en essayant de laisser toute la déjà
toute la liberté à l'autre de l'éveiller
à ça mais aussi surtout toute la liberté
à l'enfant davantage c'est le jour du
seigneur c'est pas le même nom qu'elle
vendredi dans l'islam et les catholiques
donc il y aura peut être compétitif
quand je vois déjà à moi tout ce que ça
m'a apporté de te rencontrer bas de
découvrir une nouvelle culture et tout
ce qui va avec c'est énorme et je pense
que pour nos enfants et j'espère qu'on
arrivera alors alors transmettre ça en
tant que force c'est déjà pas facilement
ce n'est pas du tout facile de d'avoir
un couple durable et
et amoureux et puis donc être en plus un
couple mixte donc ça rajoute des défis
et des difficultés ça peut rajouter des
tensions grâce à la communication et à
la bienveillance la patience et le sens
du compromis où j'espère et je souhaite
comme qu'on arrive à les surmonter
et puisque je dirais aussi sur notre
couple lac est indispensable c'est
l'humour parce qu'il ya des situations
qui l'un de l'autre à peuvent nous
paraître incongru peut-être encore une
fois quand on est avec nos familles et
où nous mêmes sur d'autres points du
quotidien et
c'est à voir au rire et prend du recul
pour les aviser vu ce qui est bien de
façon plus générale quand on est un
couple mixte c'est que de toute façon on
appris en schéma qui étaient très
différents de ceux de nos parent grand
parent peu classique et donc on a en
fait beaucoup plus de liberté enfin moi
je ressens comme ça on a énormément de
liberté sur vannes aux futurs choix
c'est comme dans tous les cas on a fait
un truc très différent on serait
vraiment acteur de de ce qu'on veut
faire de nous